la crise du coronavirus n'épargne
personne pas même les artisans des
métiers de l'alimentaire maître
chocolatier philippe bayle est une
référence dans le domaine
lauréat de l'eau voire 2012 du guide des
croqueurs de chocolat meilleur ouvrier
de france en 2004
ils déplorent pourtant des pertes
économiques en ce début d'année pas
quand je leur présente un peu un bon
tiers s'ils jouent les du chiffre
d'affaires hélas cette année on a été
nommé à paqueter classe au mois de mars
on a perdu 47 % du chiffre d'affaires et
son mois d'avril et journée à 80%
pratiquement un petit peu plus les
vendeurs de chocolat sont donc fortement
touchée surtout après les périodes de
pâques mais ils ne sont pas les seuls
christian jany et fromagers et lui aussi
subi la crise du coronavirus de plein
fouet pour faire face à une baisse de la
clientèle il a parfois fallu s'adapter
le commerçant rapidement changer sa
façon de travailler
et puis notre objectif surtout c'était
de par le souvenir des producteurs des
producteurs fermiers landais fermiers et
artisanaux faut savoir que déjà à
l'agriculture c'est les gens qui s'en
voit au quotidien hongrois des gros
revenus donc voilà le but c'était
c'était de continuer à pouvoir écouler
leur production
donc on a mis davantage d'énergie à
essayer de devancer pierrot par rapport
à des gens adhèrent tous deux reconnus
comme commerce essentiel les
établissements de christian jany et
philippe baile peuvent donc continuer
leurs activités
cela ne les a pas empêchés d'être
touchée par les conséquences de la crise
sanitaire des commerçants qui espèrent
renouer avec leur rythme habituel après
le déconfinement prévue pour le 11 mai
prochain